Speaker 1: Today, we're going to be speaking
with Thomas Gabor, who's a criminologist and
author of five books on gun violence, including
American Carnage Shattering the Myths that
Fuel Gun Violence.
Tom, really appreciate your time today.
Thanks for joining me.
Speaker 5: My pleasure to be with you, David.
Speaker 1: So, I mean, let's just start with
a very simple premise and see if there is
anything to it.
Some of those in the United States who don't
want to see any additional gun safety regulations
or laws put in place say they wouldn't do
anything to reduce shootings anyway.
Is that a claim that we can actually debunk
with with data?
Do gun safety regulations reduce shootings?
Speaker 5: Certain ones do.
And, you know, I just came across another
report today that showed, for example, that
red states are states that are run mostly
by a governor, a governor who's a Republican
or a Republican legislature, which tend to
have weaker gun laws, have much higher gun
mortality rates.
So there's a lot of evidence that, first of
all, there's a correlation between gun ownership
and gun mortality.
There's a tendency that gun ownership levels
go up in the states and there's huge variations
there.
They there tends to be an increase in gun
mortality or gun deaths and gun homicides
as well.
So and as well, we see when we rate states
in terms of the weakness or strength of the
gun laws, the stronger the gun laws, the lower
gun mortality tends to be.
Speaker 1: What can you give a couple of examples
of the types of regulations that are effective
and then maybe a couple of examples of the
ones that maybe aren't so much?
Speaker 5: Okay.
Well, good question.
First of all, I've studied gun licensing around
the world, and that requires a much thorough,
more thorough background check than we do
here in the United States, where you have
interviews with law enforcement, you have
reference checks and so forth.
And those countries tend to do a whole lot
better than we do.
And we see some states that have some kind
of owner licensing, such as Connecticut, that
have done better than other states, and they've
seen gun homicides go down.
Another one is storage.
Safe storage seems to make an enormous difference
or what we also call child access prevention
laws.
So when we have consequences for people not
securely storing their guns in terms of legal
consequences, that seems to make a difference.
Because, for example, we've seen many school
shooters, these young men who've either often
obtained their guns not always, but often
from the home or the home of a relative, and
these guns were not secured.
Now, as far as what doesn't work, because,
you know, it's only in the last few years
that the federal government has been able
to conduct research because there's been an
attempt by allies of the gun lobby to stop
all research in this area.
We hear a lot about universal background checks.
I'd like to make a clarification there, because
what that means is that and this is why people
are seeking that every individual buys a gun,
has to have a background check.
So today we have this you might call it a
loophole where if you buy on the private market,
you buy through the Internet or from gun stores,
you don't need to go undergo a background
check if you've not bought from a licensed
dealer.
So I'm all for that.
However, the background check system also,
in my view, is broken.
And if all we do is expand background checks
to all sales, it's not sufficient because
there are enormous problems with the system
itself.
It's a two minute check of three FBI databases.
And so we've had people like the Parkland
shooter who showed all kinds of disturbing
signs, but because he didn't have a criminal
felony record, he was able to buy his AR 15
legally from a gun store.
So we need the analogy I use is, you know,
we pretty well have universal checks.
When we get on a plane, everybody gets checked.
But the second question is not just does everybody
get checked, but how good is that detection?
Right.
That's through a lot of guns and explosives.
Then you can check everybody, but it's not
sufficient.
So what I'm saying here is the background,
the quality of the background check system
itself has to be improved.
I don't believe that just expanding background
checks is sufficient.
Speaker 1: What about ideas like restricting
the ability to purchase certain firearms to
individuals of a certain age?
So maybe if you're under 25, certain firearms
would not be legal, legally purchasable?
I mean, with all these things, you can always
say, well, then that person will figure out
how to get that firearm illegally.
But it's like, maybe they won't.
Some of them won't.
Speaker 5: Right.
And you know, that argument that, you know,
criminals will always be criminals.
And it's such a gross oversimplification.
Yeah.
You know, and therefore, we can't stop somebody
who.
Determined to get a gun?
Well, first of all, a lot of gun violence
isn't committed, isn't premeditated, it's
spontaneous.
So if you happen to be carrying around the
gun and you get into a fight or a road rage
incident, you're more likely to pull that
gun.
But the other thing is that if we use that
logic, we get rid of all laws because you
can't stop all molestation or rape or homicide
and so forth.
So but some people are deterred.
And you make it more difficult because what's
easier than allowing somebody who is showing
some disturbing behavior to simply because
they don't have a criminal record on file,
especially a felony record, to just walk in
and purchase a gun in 2 minutes.
Right.
You know, and they could be also very aggravated,
angry about something.
So I think, though, the age issue that you
mentioned would be helpful because we do have
quite a few people are committing gun violence.
After that, it becomes much more difficult
legally because a person can argue in court
that, well, I'm you know, I'm old enough to
go fight for the country.
I'm old enough to vote.
It also, you know, you don't have the right
to kind of a breach my rights.
Speaker 1: And, Tom, we lost we lost your
file.
We lost your audio just for a second where
I think what you were saying was it's easier
to restrict based on based on age before people
are 18.
Was that the argument you were making?
But that these in-between ages can be tough
legally?
Speaker 5: Yeah, though, you know, 18 to 21,
I mean, that's passed in a number of states
in the past in Florida as well, before the
legislature tried to repeal that.
Yeah.
So 18 to 21, I say, is probably as high as
you can go.
Got it.
And there are people challenging that as well,
saying that they can vote, they could serve
the country at 18 and so forth.
So they should be able to purchase a gun.
But leaving the legal arguments alone, I think
18 to 21, certainly those are some of the
most active years for people committed to
gun violence.
So raising that age can be helpful.
Speaker 1: I want to talk about the issue
of mental health.
And there are so many aspects to this.
You know, on the one hand, colloquially speaking,
without diagnosing anyone, it when I think
about a mass shooting, it seems that we would
say anyone who gets to a point where this
is something they would go and do, they're
probably, quote, mentally ill in some way
because no sane person would do that.
This is a very simplistic thing to say, but
in some sense, many of us would say no sane
person who's emotionally regulated and whatever,
whatever commits such an act.
So in a sense, certainly mental health is
a component.
But what do we really mean when we say that?
Are we talking about somebody who has anxiety
and sees a therapist?
What is it exactly that we're trying to get
at when we talk about mental health?
How do you believe the mental health layer
should be applied to the gun safety regulations
layer?
Speaker 5: Well, we call it the mental illness.
Dodge.
There's a world of difference between saying
that somebody has a severe mental illness
like schizophrenia, bipolar disease, psychosis
or something like that.
And only 4% of people commit violent crimes
of the country have a severe mental illness.
Now, what you're talking about is often individuals
who are agitated.
In fact, one of the frightening statistics
in this country is that over 20 million individuals
have serious anger issues.
There are people who have a short trigger,
if you wish, and are quick to anger, have
impulsive anger issues and also own guns.
This is a much bigger problem.
So, yes, I mean, when you're talking about
somebody who commits a mass shooting or even
a shooting of one individual, that they're
agitated, they're angry, but we all get angry
at times.
And so there's a world of difference between
somebody suffering from major mental illness
and they're usually more of a danger to themselves
in terms of suicides, and they're more likely
to be victims of crime.
We see that with the homeless, some of the
homeless mentally ill who are victimized in
different cities, but they're much less of
a concern unless they also had, in addition
to a serious mental illness, a history of
violence.
I'd be more concerned with people who are
already at a moment's notice to deploy guns
against intruders or people who may be an
intruder.
You know, these recent incidents where somebody
took a turn around driveway and was shot at
and somebody else who knocked on the wrong
door, I'm more concerned about all these people
now because they've been sold the gun lobby's
narrative that you're safer with a gun in
the home.
And, you know, the gun lobby has done a lot
to stoke people's fears and they're ready.
They have 40% now of people have guns in the
home, have the guns loaded and accessible.
That's what I'm talking about.
And if they also have a shorter trigger and
they're also afraid, very, very afraid, because
this fear has been stoked for decades now,
I'm more concerned about those individuals
because the guns are at the ready and they're
primed to commit an act of violence.
Speaker 1: Yet you're getting to now going
beyond mental illness into a cultural component.
And one of the.
Things that is different in the United States
than in many other countries where I've spent
time is that there is a gun culture, which
I describe it as.
It sees firearms as a more valid way to resolve
interpersonal issues, frustrations, political
issues, etc., which access a side.
And of course, we have to talk about access.
Access aside, I don't see in a lot of the
other countries where I've spent time is this
intangible cultural difference a reality in
the United States?
Speaker 5: Well, you know, this is what we
take on.
One of the myths we take on in our book American
Carnage, because in reality, first of all,
there is no all encompassing gun culture in
the United States.
We have entire regions like New England, where
you have gun ownership levels in certain areas,
only 15 to 20%.
Right.
Only a third of American adults are gun owners.
Now, if you're talking about a minority of
individuals who you might say have a gun fetish
in stock or a large arsenal of guns, we're
talking about maybe what we call the super
owners who are 6% of the American population
and they own two thirds of all the guns.
Wow.
That doesn't make them all dangerous at all.
But these are the people who have more of
a gun fetish, if you want to call it that.
And some of them are just collectors.
But the vast majority of the population isn't
like that.
But let me tell you, what's changed is in
1977, the National Rifle Association got taken
over by a very extremist group of people,
and they have now spent over 40 years trying
to convince Americans that if you arm yourself
in the home and carry guns, you're going to
be a lot more safe.
The other thing they did is because with the
decline of hunting and the end of the draft
and the military draft was where many people
were introduced to guns and the increasing
urbanization of the country, there was a real
crunch on the gun industry.
So they started pushing this narrative of
self-protection.
So this is only about 40 years old, this narrative
that we should all have guns.
We're safer with guns in the home carrying
guns.
In fact, in the 1800s, most of the states
banned the carrying of concealed firearms.
So we actually in the United States have a
history going back to the revolutionary period
of regulating firearms, even having citizens
forming a militia and asking them once a year
to show up at the town square to show why
the guns you have.
And those guns could be seized by the militia
if there was an attack on the country or some
revolution to put down.
So we've had a history, actually, the Old
West, you had gun ordinances, but it's more
recently the last 40 years that we've departed
from that history.
And what you call a gun culture is really
an attempt by extremists and a gun lobby to
promote the idea of the armed citizenry being
safer.
But we see that it's not the you know, it's
so far from the truth.
And what we're seeing is the opposite more
mass shooting, more gun deaths, children now,
the number one cause of death of Americans
up to 19 is is gunfire and so forth.
So things have really moved in the in the
opposite direction from what they're claiming.
Speaker 1: The book is American Carnage Shattering
the Myths That Fuel Gun Violence.
We've been speaking with Thomas Gabor, criminologist.
Really appreciate your time and insights today.
Speaker 5: Thank you, David.
It's been a pleasure.